un conseil
lâcher nos utérus si vous souhaitez
téléphone si vous souhaitez aider les
femmes faites l'égalité salariale le
congé paternité
et qui vous congelez maternité laissez
partir avec les femmes avant 64 ans avec
les trimestres à qui retirez votre
réforme nos vôtres ne sont pas la
variable d'ajustement de votre réforme
des retraites
[Musique]
pour garantir la pérennité de notre
système par répartition il n'y a pas que
le taux d'emploi à améliorer il y a
également le taux de fécondité car sans
enfant demain il n'y aura pas de
renouvellement des générations or la
natalité en disant a chuté le taux de
fécondité est tombé à 1,8 alors que le
désir de maternité dans le même temps
c'est maintenu à 2,3 enfants par femme
j'envoie certains qui rigolent mais je
peux vous dire que c'est un sujet très
sérieux la natalité et la grande absente
avec la productivité d'ailleurs de votre
réforme des retraites qui est quand même
aberrant parce que on le sait aucune
ambition sociale de ce pays n'aurait pu
être faite si nous n'avions pas eu une
natalité florissante je remercie la
gauche d'arrêter de culpabiliser les
femmes qui veulent figurez-vous de leur
plein gré avoir des des enfants ça fait
10 jours que vous vous tapissez dans
l'ombre de la nupes et la voilà que vous
sortez de votre grotte pour faire quoi
raviver non pas vos vieux démons mais
vos démons actuels il y a un problème
c'est les femmes les femmes ne sont
qu'un utérus les femmes sont là pour
régler le problème de la société au
travers de quoi leur natalité mais bien
sûr mais bien sûr continuez à nous
expliquer que nous ne sommes que des
ventres mesdames continuez à le faire et
ensuite à nous expliquer que vous êtes
des féministes hors pair chers collègues
écoutez je sais pas ce qui s'est passé
et dû avoir une faille temporelle où on
était transporté dans un débat qui
n'existe pas à partir d'un d'un
amendement de nos collègues galères qui
cherchent à donner plus de liberté
économique aux femmes plus de sécurité
aux familles on en revient à débat
complètement caricatural où il faisait
croire qu'on veut assigner les femmes à
je ne sais quel foyer
[Musique]